[Music]
working as a Disneyland princess seems
like it would be the job of your dreams
turns out working as a princess doesn't
mean you get to live in a fairy tale
watch until the end to see how being a
Disney princess could even be dangerous
if this is your first time visiting the
things don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
here's 10 secrets Disneyland princesses
are not allowed to talk about if you
like crafts and DIYs check out our
friends at crafty hackers they have this
awesome video about ways you can recycle
regular objects into toys they'll show
you how to turn your useless everyday
items into amazing kids toys make sure
you check them out
and be sure to leave them a like click
in the corner to watch can't choose your
princess applicants who want to work as
a Disneyland princess don't get to
choose which princess to audition for
anyone who wishes to become a full-time
Disney princess must attend an open
audition for any role which includes
princesses princes and fur characters as
well as parade performers a former
Disney cast members spoke to BuzzFeed
about the process saying that the first
categorization was done based on height
after that the process of elimination
begins based on what roles Disney needs
to have filled at that time for this
reason people who audition might have to
do so multiple times though they might
be a perfect fit for a certain character
they might be hiring for an entirely
different princess at that time a former
Disney worker explained on reddit that
each person can only attend one audition
a year therefore if you're not lucky and
end up auditioning for a character that
isn't needed you might have to wait
another year before trying again the
audition involves reading lines and
choreography before the actors are
chosen to fulfill their roles in one
instance a Disney worker tells Insider
that out of 500 girls who auditioned
only three were picked to become a
Rapunzel and Aurora and a Snow White
tattoos there are too many people to
count who choose to get Disney related
tattoos yet if you want to work as a
Disney princess you will need to make
sure you're devoid of tattoos or at
least that you find a way to cover them
Disney's internships and program
website outlines the details of their no
tattoo policy concealing tattoos must
only be done with the use of clothing or
makeup and it should be natural-looking
so the cover-up isn't noticeable long
sleeved undershirts can also be worn to
make sure tattoos cannot be seen while
working at a park these rules don't just
apply to princesses but also to all
Disney workers the rule extends to
prohibiting body piercings earlobe
expansions or disfiguring skin implants
this would also make it much more
limiting for those wanting to audition
for Jazmin Moana Pocahontas and Ariel
for example they would have to make sure
they could somehow hide their tattoos
some have commented on the role saying
that it's outdated and Disney should be
more inclusive in a day and age where
tattoos and piercings are so popular
what do you think would it ruin the
illusion for you if you met your
favorite Disney Princess and she had a
visible tattoo social media posts actors
who have been cast as Disneyland
princesses have said that seeing
themselves in full costume for the first
time is often a surreal experience it's
only natural to think that it would make
for a great Instagram or snapchat post
but hold up Disneyland princesses have
to be extremely careful to lock down
their social media while they can post
about other aspects of their lives
Disneyland princesses are not allowed to
post about anything related to their
jobs they aren't allowed to reveal which
character they portray or take any
pictures backstage since this would ruin
the illusion and could result in
spoiling the magic it's important that
working as a Disney Princess is never
revealed to the public
Disney calls this the oath of
confidentiality and violating this oath
can even result in losing your job while
at work Disney Princesses are not
allowed to talk or show that they know
anything about the world outside of
Disney they aren't allowed to reference
characters that aren't part of the realm
meanwhile they are not supposed to talk
about their Disney field day with
friends and family the amount of secrecy
involved with living in a fairy tale as
a Disney princess is almost like being a
spy autograph training an autograph book
is essential during a vacation to
Disneyland and kids will wait in long
lines to get a picture and autograph
from their face
at Disney Princess in order to make this
weight worth every second
dizzy make sure that all details are
accounted for so that meeting at
Disneyland princess feels like the real
deal
one of the reasons that training to work
as a Disneyland princess is a five-week
grueling process is because there are
always more than one of each princess
sometimes this may even occur at the
same time but in different locations
within the park
there are several protocols in place to
make sure the two of the same Disney
Princesses are never within close
proximity of one another nevertheless
this means that it's very important to
ensure consistency so that the Snow
White you saw at lunch in Epcot doesn't
seem different from the snow white you
see later in the afternoon in Magic
Kingdom one of these details that need
to remain consistence are the princesses
individual autographs the autographs are
taught in the training process to make
sure that each autograph book would look
the same from year to year even if the
actress changes code words for
emergencies one very important rule for
anyone who works as a disneyland
princess is to never break character
working in a theme park and constantly
being surrounded by children is not
always incident-free
in fact it's pretty likely for a child
to have a bathroom accident be sick or
fall and scrape their knee however it
wouldn't be very princess-like to yell
out that someone just threw up nearby
instead princesses have to learn a code
to be able to communicate incidents such
as code VIII for a throw up incident or
code you for a bathroom incident there's
even a code H for a parade horse that
poops while working it wouldn't be very
princess-like to have to discuss bodily
functions but there's another reason for
these type of codes in a lot of
instances meeting a Disney princess is a
dream come true and it would be
embarrassing to hear your role model
talk about how you lost control of your
bladder while waiting in line to see
them using a code system also helps make
sure that no one feels insecure after
all Disney is meant to be the happiest
place on earth
pointing with two fingers ever notice
how the Statue of Walt Disney and Mickey
in the Magic Kingdom shows that Walt is
pointing using two fingers instead of
one well he's not the only one in fact
it's a requirement that all disneyland
princesses have to point using both the
there's as well this might seem strange
but there are actually some pretty good
reasons for it one of the reasons is
that in many cultures such as China
Japan Indonesia and Latin America it is
considered to be rude to point with one
finger in some African countries it is
believed that people should never be
pointed at rather only inanimate objects
therefore the two finger point rule is
actually very culturally sensitive
considering so many people travel from
around the world to see fairy tales come
to life another reason is that using
both fingers makes it easier for smaller
children to see what is being pointed
out feel free to test this theory by
asking a Disneyland princess for
directions once you're there as they are
also expected to know everything there
is to know about the park itself if a
princess's answer to a question
regarding Disneyland is I don't know
they can actually be fired because of it
clean up like a princess who would you
guess would be in charge of picking up
garbage in a castle we're willing you
didn't guess that the princesses do yet
they are absolutely expected to at
Disneyland the concept of this rule
really speaks to how Disney treats all
its employees the same princesses like
any other Disneyland employee must pick
up any garbage they see lying around on
the ground with so many visitors it's
expected that some garbage might litter
the ground but no one wants the Disney
illusion to be shattered because of
wrappers papers and cups lying around on
the ground in order to keep the park as
clean as possible all Disneyland
employees are expected to contribute to
their work environment and clean up
whenever they can however there is a
weird secret aspects related to the
technique used to pick up trash
princesses are not allowed to just bend
down or squat to pick up garbage in
order to throw it out instead a princess
should swoop and scoop the garbage they
find in a way that looks graceful and
still princess like if only real life
birds and forest animals could join
princesses in their swoop and scoop
cleaning it would really be like a
Disney movie come to life looks matter a
lot Disney has suffered a lot of
criticism for its unrealistic beauty
standards when it comes to their
princesses yet these same standards
apply to the actors who portray our
favorite Disney Princesses at Disneyland
even something
specific as Heights can be a
make-or-break when it comes to becoming
a Disneyland princess only applicants
between 5 feet 3 inches and 5 feet 7
inches are considered for becoming
princesses villains on the other hands
can be as tall as 5 feet 10 inches
different heights correspond to
different princesses for some princesses
with more revealing costumes like
Jasmine it's also specified that a
Disney worker will need to have a toned
stomach women can only wear sheer nail
polish or none at all
as for jewelry one pair of earrings and
one ring is all that is allowed
princesses also have to put on their own
makeup but still make sure that all
actors look the same when dressed up as
the same princess there are specific
step-by-step instructions to follow for
each individual princess people are cast
as the Disney princess they most
resemble so when it comes to auditioning
looks and more important than Talent
princesses should also always be smiling
and should never sit down no job
security
Disneyland princesses need to jump
through hoops in order to get hired but
the worst part is there is no guarantee
how long they will be able to keep their
position for one thing there are age
restrictions for how long a princess can
work for the average age of retirements
for a Disneyland princess is 27 there's
also a limit as to how long Disneyland
princesses are allowed to keep their
jobs princesses are also given clickers
to keep track of how many visitors they
receive every hour if a princess
receives less than 172 visitors which
amounts to 30 seconds per guest they
will get reprimanded and could even lose
their job prentices also have to
re-audition every six months to make
sure they are still living up to
Disneyland standards during these relook
s-- employees are judged on their body
shape skin and overall look to make sure
they still resemble a disney princess a
princess can also lose their job at any
time because they are disapproved of
this has happened before when an
employee's arms got too large and when
another employee had an acne breakout
all over her face dangerous job it
doesn't seem like being in Disneyland
princess could have any risks associated
with it but a surprising secret is that
it absolutely can be in order to become
a Disneyland princess everyone must fur
be a character performer in fuzzy
costumes and masks
after this they can begin training for
their princess human roles however it
gets really hot as these fur costumes
can weigh up to 47 pounds
these cumbersome outfits are also
dangerous an article in Mental Floss
says that across the world with all the
Disney parks combined data showed that
in 2005 49 of the 773 total injuries
were as a result of the heavy costume
heads 107 of the earlier mentioned
injuries were because pushing pooling or
other aggressive behaviors from guests
one performer suffered with lash from
the weight of her Minnie Mouse head
moving back and forth when a guests
picked her up and shook her even once
graduated to a princess there is a
potential for injury according to
Cosmopolitan princesses have broken
knees and dislocated shoulders because
of the weight of the wire frame under
their large princess gowns the process
of becoming a princess is definitely
grueling and even potentially dangerous
let us know which secrets surprised you
the most that's all for ten secrets
Disneyland princesses are not allowed to
talk about if this is your first time
visiting the things don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up see you next time
[Music]